[Music]
on this sunday night canada versus china
will the exchange of two canadians and a
chinese citizen improve relations there
was no path to a relation with china as
long as the two michaels were detained
the protests over kovalev 19 passports
plus the canadian basketball player who
tried to avoid the shot
a rare interview with the late john
lennon well the beatles don't usually
plan their future you know we play
everything by ear the treasure trove
discovered by canadian family and the
touching tribute to canada's lost
indigenous children
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us they spent more than a thousand days
imprisoned in china but michael kovrick
and michael spavor are enjoying their
first full day back on canadian soil
their detention was seen as retaliation
for the arrest of huawei executive mong
wong zhou who's now back in china but
the 10th standoff between the two
countries didn't end there ottawa
delayed decisions on chinese 5g
technology beijing blocked canadian
agricultural products the relationship
is deeply damaged and as eric sorensen
reports it will be difficult to repair
so much has changed since prime minister
trudeau looked to deepen trade ties with
china five years ago the seizure of
michael spavor and michael calvrig
paralyzed relations for almost three
years the end of this stalemate makes it
possible to re-engage but there will be
pressure on canada to establish a new
and tougher foreign policy toward china
on global's the west block canada's
foreign affairs minister mark garneau
said this country will cooperate in
areas like climate change but is
prepared to stand up to china sometimes
we will challenge china as we did on
their arbitrary detention of the two
michaels as we did on their treatment of
the uyghurs the people of hong kong the
tibetans and we're going to continue to
challenge china as we move forward so
the relationship is a complex one but
our eyes are wide open the potential of
this
case and its resolution
means that there'll be just a little bit
more room for cooperation but says
jeremy paul teal the relationship has
changed china's relationship with the
international community
and and also the perception of the
canadian public
will not go back to what it was before
the decisions with china will be
difficult hundreds of thousands of
canadians live in china our economy
depends on china how hard will ottawa
press on human rights will it approve or
ban huawei's 5g technology and with the
new u.s uk australia security pact for
nuclear submarines will canada step up
on global security last week
washington's nominee for ambassador to
canada was blunt that the americans want
to see greater clarity from canada
towards china we are all waiting for
canada to release
its framework for its overall china
policy and make sure that canada's
policies
reflect its words
in terms of the treatment of of
of china and that we do improve the
collaboration and coordination between
our two countries in taking on the
existential threat that is china what's
needed say experts is a new canadian
foreign policy that recognizes china's
willingness to exercise its growing
power we have moved them into a new
different era lynette ong says china is
confident and increasingly belligerent
the honors is now up to the liberal
government to come up with a coherent
china policy as to how we have to deal
with this rising power in the near
future one of the first signs of
canada's direction could come with a
decision to ban or approve huawei's 5g
technology our primary consideration
is ensuring the security our
telecommunications system and when we're
ready to make that decision we will make
it it's one of many decisions to be made
in reshaping canada's relationship with
china after three years of deep and
mutual mistrust eric sorensen global
news toronto
ontario is the latest province to impose
proof of vaccination requirements for
access to non-essential businesses and
services those opposed to the policy of
pushing back and taking their anger out
on businesses in toronto they swarmed a
popular downtown shopping center
flooding public health orders and ashan
o'shea reports there are calls for more
police action to stop confrontations
like that
the ballet dancer performing in front of
toronto's eaton center sunday in stark
contrast to what happened here a day
earlier
a tussle between security police and
protesters trying to barge inside north
america's busiest shopping mall these
individuals tried
storming into the eaton center unmasked
and defying actively defying
mass mandates vaccine mandates
in order to
assert what are perceived to be rights
protests over mandatory masks and
vaccinations aren't new but now instead
of just shouting slogans or marching
protesters here were urged to go inside
to make a point the rhetoric is
inherently violent because it is calling
for people to endanger others
by refusing to to comply with public
health orders two people involved have
now been arrested and charged with
assault
protesters have barged into other malls
without being stopped walking inside
without masks and refusing to comply
with ontario's new proof of vaccination
program it requires people dining inside
restaurants or food courts to prove
they're fully vaccinated you guys do you
guys report on the truth since the rules
took effect no one's been arguing with
us they're or trying to push their own
agendas on us restaurants like the queen
and beaver haven't had pushback
management and staff support the mandate
we know who's vaccinated and you know
makes me feel more happy when i know all
these people are vaccinated so i i feel
safer as a person working here and so
they do so do the employees here too
scenes like these at malls are a concern
to some shoppers a lot of people are
coming to the malls pretending hoping
that it's safe to environment to shop in
but people coming and barging in and
things like that of course it creates
chaos which is something that's
unnecessary in 18 months since protests
began police have done little
enforcement says lawyer kareem assad who
records the protests each week the
police have gone from
escorting to total non-action at a
vaccination clinic held inside another
shopping mall toronto's mayor was asked
whether the police should be stepping up
enforcement if i went and caused a fuss
about anything in the street and i
started pushing people around or trying
to jam my way into a building in an
unpeaceful manner then i would expect i
would get arrested i would know that's
the consequence the law office his duty
is to make sure that they do that and if
they're not doing that they should be
subjected to arrest a common view but
the decision to arrest and charge is
something entirely in the hands of
police sean o'shea global news toronto
the thousands of people attending
toronto blue jays games will of course
be required to show their proof of
vaccination professional sports leagues
are trying to balance between having
fans in the stands and respecting local
health requirements the rules are clear
for spectators in most places but as
mike delay explains when it comes to
players hopping between cities it's a
little more complicated
the blue jays nest is filling up this
week capacity at rogers center will
increase from 15 to 30 thousand fans a
decision that was made after ontario's
vaccination rate surpassed eighty
percent i'm confident that we can do
this safely and slowly and cautiously um
because we all need balance the one
caveat is that everybody entering the
stadium will have to show proof of
vaccination like it or not infectious
disease specialists say it's the only
way any of this will work even if we go
back a couple months ago a lot of places
weren't talking about vaccine passports
but more and more we're realizing that
that's really the way out
of
of this pandemic to keep
employees and
the patrons safe so for fans it's
straightforward for athletes like
toronto born nba star andrew wiggins it
can be complicated wiggins is the lone
vaccine holdout on the golden state
warriors which play in a san francisco
arena with very strict passport rules
the nba denied him a religious exemption
so unless he gets vaccinated he can't
play in any home games which will impact
his 31 million dollar annual salary his
decision is kind of like
a case study as to how
sports and companies and organizations
deal with individuals who uh
i don't know how someone wants to even
describe what he's doing because it's
such a
touchy subject right now other leagues
have used the carrot and the stick
approach
minus the carrot the nfl's vaccination
rate is 93 percent in large part because
the rules for unvaxxed players are so
strict still there are holdouts i
respect everybody else's decision and
you know i just ask that everybody does
the same for me and this week a handful
of nhl teams ran into the same issue
some sent their unvaccinated players to
the minor leagues citing headaches with
border restrictions and quarantines
all things nobody wants to talk about
anymore way above my pay grade
way about my career i'm not going to
talk about
vaccinations covet i want to talk about
hockey
wouldn't that be nice
mike drew like global news toronto
canada is just out of direction and the
new session of the parliament has not
been set yet but that gives justin
trudeau time to pick his new cabinet and
for the first time in two years there
will be a representative from alberta
let's bring in our chief political
correspondent david aiken david
well robin there is one prime directive
that all prime ministers must follow
when creating a cabinet if they can they
want at least one representative from
every province and now with two liberals
elected in alberta for the first time in
two years it's a lock that one or more
likely both will go into cabinet
what a pleasure to be back in calgary
george chahall is the new mp for calgary
sky view i'm so grateful for the
opportunity to be a voice for calgary
and northeast calgary and ottawa and
randy bossina was re-elected in edmonton
center after losing that seat in 2019.
we had lost that progressive voice from
alberta in the federal government and
now we have that voice but justin
trudeau also has his own golden rule for
cabinet making there must be an equal
number of men and women he's never
wavered on that since forming his first
cabinet because it's 2015.
now with all 18 male incumbent ministers
re-elected and with the two additions
from alberta you've got a cabinet that
could have as many as 20 men but only 14
returning ministers are women so trudeau
will need as many as six fresh female
faces in cabinet to achieve gender
parity
one sure bet lena diab from halifax west
she's the only female liberal mp for
nova scotia and she's a former justice
minister from that province darielle
carabas teddy qarabag
another likely pick in london west ariel
kaiabaga a member of london city council
she is bilingual and as a black woman
would help trudeau increase the
diversity in his cabinet boom to the
liberals again
other possibilities leah taylor roy a
harvard trained consultant just elected
in aurora oak ridge's richmond hill or
helena jazic a former ontario health
minister re-elected in markham
stouffville or kamal kara a nurse
re-elected in brampton west
and all of that means that trudeau is
going to disappoint many male back
benchers who might have been hoping for
a promotion into one of those 275 000 a
year cabinet jobs there just will not be
room in trudeau's gender parity cabinet
for any more fellas robin david aiken in
ottawa thanks david
results are starting to come in from
germany's election where the race is too
close to call so far the country's
social democratic party holds a narrow
lead over angela merkel's conservative
bloc her party is headed for its worst
result since 1949. the tight results
show no party has enough support for a
majority and a coalition could be needed
to form government so whoever succeeds
merkel as chancellor is still up in the
air
the celebrations have begun in
switzerland after voters overwhelmingly
supported marriage equality in a
nationwide referendum 64 voted in favor
of the marriage for all measure since
2007 switzerland has authorized lgbtq
couples to register civil partnerships
but it's one of the last countries in
western europe to allow them to marry
the measure also opens the door for
same-sex couples to adopt children
coming up the amtrak train that derailed
on a popular route near the canadian
border
[Music]
in the u.s at least three people were
killed and dozens more were injured when
an amtrak passenger train careened off
the tracks it happened in montana not
far from the canadian border while on
route from chicago to seattle images
from the scene show several cars flipped
on their sides jennifer johnson reports
on the investigation
oh my god it's on its side in clear
weather and along a straightaway the
amtrak empire builder train started to
derail near joplin montana about 48
kilometers from the canadian border
passengers say it happened in seconds
just long enough for wayne freed to hold
on for his life in the lounge car i was
lucky and that i
was able to grab a hold of the coffee
table it was starting to tip
and then there was a scraping noise it's
just like a kind of a shock thing i
guess i just couldn't believe that it
actually was happening the national
transportation safety board's team of
investigators will try and determine
what caused eight of the cars to derail
some experts believe high temperatures
warming the tracks may have been a
factor it was about 32 degrees celsius
at the time of the accident there is an
ongoing investigation with bnsf amtrak
and
ntsb we ask that people stay clear of
the area until the investigation is
complete as far as hospitals
most people were treated and released
amtrak has had a handful of accidents
but hasn't had a train derail since
december 2017. that train was traveling
at more than twice the speed limit in
washington state sending passenger cars
tumbling from a bridge killing three
people many travelers on this train were
taken to a nearby school thankful to be
alive i was laying down in my in my
compartment on a bed
so luckily i just tumbled just in the
room i heard a loud bang and then the
cars tipped the train was carrying more
than 140 passengers and 16 crew members
the ntsb has no timetable for releasing
its findings its report could take
months jennifer johnson global news
washington
imagine finding john lennon's voice in
your house we'll explain when global
national continues
you're watching global national
[Music]
does this sound familiar john lennon and
paul mccartney are topping music charts
again with a hip-hop take on their song
michelle canadian rapper drake listed
the two beatles as co-writers on his
number four hit champagne poetry
the band remains one of the most
influential in history in newly
discovered interviews going as far back
as 1969 lennon talks about what
influenced the beatles a canadian family
found the rare tapes which go on auction
this week as crystal gomezing reports
they're a priceless piece of music
history
[Music]
what beetle music do you look upon as
being outstanding
well i'm prejudiced i like my own you
know
and so i don't know you know i like
revolution number nine one voice a music
legend the other a canadian journalist
from winnipeg
name other favorites from the 60s walrus
strawberry fields day in the life
why walrus for instance because i wrote
it and i like it you know
the late ken zielig's multiple
interviews with john lennon and yoko ono
were discovered this past summer a
beatles treasure hidden away in los
angeles in the garage of his youngest
daughter the family has chosen to put
the reels all 91 minutes up for auction
interesting topics that he covers are
the you know the songs that he was
he likes the beatles songs that he likes
his relationship with the beatles
his his love for yoko and their
relationship the beatles are a cultural
touchstone the abbey road crosswalk is
proof of that it's one of the most
pictured locations in london hannah
zelik the eldest daughter didn't want to
go on camera but she did tell me sitting
and listening to her dad's recordings
made it feel like john lennon was in her
home speaking directly to her an
experience up for grabs comes september
28th
music writer and broadcaster alan cross
says demand for beatles memorabilia is
endless and these recordings
are rare the idea of being the owner of
a number of interviews that have never
been released to anybody up until this
time that's a pretty good bit of
memorabilia john could you give me some
idea what the beatles plan to do in the
future
well the beatles don't usually plan
their future you know we play everything
by ear
let me take you down
gold dust unearthed during a pandemic
cleaning spree
crystal gomanson global news
london
up next an artist honors the lost
children of residential
schools the pain is still fresh for the
more than 200 unmarked graves found at
the former residential school in
kamloops bc now there are plans to carve
a permanent monument in memory of the
indigenous children who have yet to be
identified julia foy spoke to the artist
tasked with the tribute and the vision
that's inspiring him and a warning some
of the details may be distressing
when i first looked at it i saw
this would be the owl's head
and having its wing extended here darcy
basil is about to transform this 1100
kilogram jade boulder into a tribute to
the lost children of the kamloops
residential school
my dad went to the campus residential
school and so
he told me these stories that's why it
was so hard for me
i wasn't able to work the vancouver
artist wanted to find a way to help
survivors heal it wasn't until he was
offered the jade from the yukon that the
inspiration came to him in our culture
the owl represents death but
on the other side of it thou represents
taking your spirit and guiding it to the
spirit world he traveled to kamloops to
consult with the tekamloops sequem the
band had a similar vision they
photocopied a story about
the owl
taking the child because he didn't
listen
and brought him away and raised him
basil had a third confirmation after an
encounter with a bird i went for a walk
in the trails
and
owl flew by me about a foot in front of
my face and
turned and dropped a feather for me
several carvers and mentors will cheer
basil on during the next year and he's
up there now i was surprised how fast
he's progressed yeah it's been it's been
a nice journey he hopes the project
could lead to an indigenous carving
center for artists from around the world
it could turn into a
mentorship program it could turn into a
school it could turn into just about
anything yeah this is what it looks like
in its natural state the project will
begin this week coinciding with the
first national day for truth and
reconciliation i think the jade piece is
something that will last for thousands
of years and it's strong
it's resilient
and it's beautiful and just like the
ceramic people his dream is about to
take flight
julia foy global news vancouver
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm robin gill tonight your
canada is the pitt river in british
columbia we'd love to see your corner of
the country so please keep sending your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thank you for watching donna friesen
will be back at the anchor desk tomorrow
i'll see you next weekend have a great
night
[Music]
you